welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and marvel's hawkeye is now halfway
through the season with the latest
episode teasing its ultimate villain
speculated to be uncle wilson kingpin
and a recent trailer spot for the next
episodes doubling down while teasing
some even bigger reveals including
multiple ways these final episodes could
bring in major avengers characters take
a look ready
critics agree hawkeye is one of the best
shows on television
it's the most fun marvel adventure of
the year
and the biggest surprises are yet to
come
[Music]
specifically those final three shots are
the ones to really look closely at the
second of course returns to the most
important shot in episode three arguably
the most important shot in the whole
season the big cheek pinch teasing the
shady new mentor to maya lopez codenamed
uncle whom we're pretty certain is
wilson fist kingpin maybe even vincent
d'onofrio returning from playing the
character in the netflix daredevil but
until now the hawkeye series says yet to
confirm what the avengers level threat
of this storyline will be so far the
most avengers level the show has gotten
was clint firing a pimtec arrow at
another arrow to turn it giant sized and
leave another tia mutt-sized mess for
people to have to clean up but this
moment is clearly leading to something
on a higher scale because back in a
promo before the season dropped there
was this clip so kate is helping you
with an avengers level threat he's my
partner
it's kind of stretch so this must pick
up with kate and clint and eleanor's
penthouse early on in episode four after
episode three ended with jack catching
clint holding the ronin sword to his
throat kate's talk of an avengers level
threat may just be her kind of
bullshitting her mom she's just using
the term avengers level because an
avenger sitting right next to her but it
is true that the person running the
track suits acquiring texts stolen from
the wreckage of avengers compound is
really a threat they need to be worried
about you think that the tracksuits were
after anything else at that auction it's
pretty upsetting to think there might be
stuff in the avengers compound floating
around out there now some of that
avengers tech is clearly safe in clint's
hands with that pimtec arrow which must
have been engineered for him by hank
pimps sometime after in-game but some
other tech is definitely making its way
around the black market which is what
this latest trailer begins to show us a
new angle of the sequence that we've
seen in other promo footage clint and
kate on the ice rink at 30 rockefeller
center fighting members of the tracksuit
mafia except now high voltage
electricity spreads through the
flagpoles that surround the rink it's
hard to determine if these bolts are
leaping pole to pull or just stemming
from any one node on a pole they aren't
coming from those six blue lights those
were already set up to make the rank
look blue that are visible when other
characters are walking up to the rank
other trailer shots but it does look
like they are coming from something
attached to one of those poles on the
left now with electric bolts like this
the mine does first go to electro who in
spider-man no way home may be in the new
york city area around the same time as
hawkeye however in no way home electro's
bolts have been deliberately redesigned
from their blue color in the amazing
spider-man 2 to the yellow color from
the comics and let's remember elektra
remains a sony property that would be
extra hard for marvel to negotiate an
appearance in an otherwise pure mcu
disney plus title rather when it comes
to blue tinted electric currents the
closest example we have seen of this
kind of vfx has been the widow's bite of
natasha romanov this is the taser
projectile that she fires from her wrist
that paralyzes her opponents you might
say this tech would have been left with
natasha on vermeer but not so fast my
friends in adventures in game especially
visible if you watch the new imax aspect
ratio released on disney plus you can
see that clint returns from vermeer at
the end of the time heist with natasha's
widow's bite now around his wrist 100
confirmation that the widow's bite made
it back to the avengers compound and was
now among the wreckage that the
auctioneers of hawkeye have harvested
from arguably even more unaccounted for
because the avenger who had to keep
track of this equipment was not there to
claim it and clint's relationship with
natasha is obviously at the heart of
this show in episode 1 he was triggered
by the natasha dancer and the musical
and the little girl cosplaying as her
leading delilah's line outside i know
everyone misses her but
she's your best friend his wife laura
reminded clint that catch and release
was natasha's move clint told ekko that
it was black widow who killed ronan
which was his way of saying that natasha
really saved him from his own violent
madness and gave him that hope don't
give me hope
i'm sorry i couldn't give it to you
sooner now sometimes i'm asked how i'm
able to uh keep my eyes open wide enough
to find all of these details and the
truth is it's just snacking folks not
just any snacking because i'm tired of
those same old snacks so i have turned
to baksu baksu is a monthly subscription
service that delivers premium japanese
snacks and tea pairings straight from
japan to your door each themed monthly
box sue box takes on a gourmet journey
through japan bok su is the only company
that partners with 100 year old family
snack makers now the first bok su you
get is called seasons of japan and it
lets you taste the seasonal flavors
popular in japan every month after that
you receive a different themed box this
month's box is
hokkaido holiday each boksu comes with a
beautifully designed booklet that tells
you where all the snacks come from who
makes them and all the allergen info you
need not to brag but i have actually
been to japan and these snacks remind me
of some of the incredible food that i
had there that i miss every day like
this delicious morsel it's a sweet
potato cookie
oh it's like a delicious shortbread
that's curiously sweet and also has a
wonderful sweet potato taste i could eat
a million of these they don't put a
million in the box which is probably a
good thing they also got some
jagapokaroo which are a little like
french fry guys look at them turn to eat
me please this is just a great gift for
that anime fan or travel lover in your
life especially during a time when
travel can be tough and if you subscribe
before december 31st you'll not only be
getting great snack boxes every month
you'll also be entered to win two free
tickets to japan so if you want to get
some awesome japanese snacks and help
support our channel of course click the
link in the description and use our code
new rockstars to get 20 off your
subscription so now it looks like the
characters of the show have rewired and
repurposed natasha's widow's fight
weapon for a new application and we
specifically do see clint in another
promo shot wiring together one of his
arrows at a workbench meaning this might
be yet another trick arrow that he adds
to his quiver and this would link up
with another mysterious promo shot of a
rooftop explosion that looks like kate
in the background firing an arrow that
causes a bright blue shock wave that
blows someone off their feet maybe maya
lopez there and it is this scene that
the final new trailer shot seems to take
place in reminding you that to come
who's that yes indeed who is this other
mystery figure wearing the night vision
goggles well it's been fitting that
we've been talking about black widow
because yelena belova is still confirmed
to appear at some point in this series
and this mystery character's night
vision goggles tactical vest exactly how
you would imagine a spy like elena would
approach a covert nighttime mission in
the black widow post-credit scene the
elena was assigned by val to hunt clint
barton i've got your next target maybe
you'd like a shot at the man responsible
for your sister's death
kind of a cutie don't you think now this
photo of clint that val has on her
tablet is the one piece of physical
evidence we know of proving that clint
barton was the same person as the ronin
assassin in this hawkeye series it's
being presented as a secret unknown to
the public unknown to the criminal
underworld and to kate bishop but val
knows which is interesting combined with
the fact that she would have any notion
at all that clint was responsible for
natasha's death like how would anyone
outside the avengers know exactly what
went down on vermeer sure val could just
claim it was clint's fault that natasha
died but for her to have any evidence
that elena would believe in order to
hold clint responsible thou must have
some source or insight into the avengers
operations extremely pervasive shadow
government oversight a scroll
information network sola eavesdropping
still tva connections sorcery
whatever narrative that yelena believes
to actually hunt clint is gonna give us
some big answers as to who val is and
the source of her power and it tells us
that clint's days of keeping his ronin
past a secret like the days counting
down to christmas are numbered this is
some christmas to support this channel
check out some of our great merch
options at newrockstarsmerch.com follow
me on instagram and twitter eaboss
follow new rockstars and subscribe to
new rockstars for more analysis and
breakdowns of everything marvel thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you
[Music]